[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم دعا رئيس الوزراء
الليبي علي زيدان الى بقاء الجماعات
المسلحه خارج العاصمه وذلك بعد مقتل
العشرات في اشتباكات بين متظاهرين ومسلحين
فتحت الباب واسعا مجددا مره اخرى للسؤال
عن مصير مساعي الدوله لضبط استخدام السلاح
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين اولا
لماذا لم تتمكن الحكومه الليبيه حتى الان
من حسم امر المظاهر المسلحه في
البلاد واي مستقبل سياسي وامني ينتظر
ليبيا اذا استمر عمل الكتائب المسلحه خارج
سلطه الدوله
قد تختلف الروايات بشان اسباب اندلاع
اشتباكات الجمعه في العاصمه الليبيه وقد
يحاول كل طرف اتهام خصف خصمه بالمسؤوليه
عنها لكن الثابت انها تمثل تطورا له ما
بعده على صعيد مساله انتشار المظاهر
المسلحه
فالحكومة
في المقابل فان الكثير من الجماعات
المسلحه لم تظهر بعد تجاوبا كافيا في هذا
الصدد اكثر من جهه مدنيه دعت لهذه التظاهر
لكنها بالتاكيد لم تتحسب نتائجها بدعوه من
مجلس طرابلس المحلي ودار الافتاء وبعض
مؤسسات المجتمع المدني تجمع هؤلاء من
مختلف احياء طرابلس للمطالبه باخراج
التشكيلات المسلحه من العاصمه الليبيه
مكان التظاهر في منطقه غرغور له دوافعه
ودلالته عند المتظاهرين حيث ان الهدف
الرئيس للمتظاهرين كان التوجه الى مقر
كتيبه النسور مصراته ومطالبتها بالخروج من
العاصمه بعد نحو اسبوع من اشتباكات كانت
طرفا فيها مع كاتبه اخرى من منطقه سوق
الجمعه في طرابلس توجه المتظاهرين الى مقر
كتبه النسور ومحاولتهم اقتحامها قوبل برد
فعل عنيف من مقاتلي الكتيبه ادى الى سقوط
قتلى وجرحى خبر الدماء التي سقطت تداعت له
كتائب اخرى من طرابلس تتبع تشكيلات الدوله
حاولت اقتحام مقر الكتيبه فزادت الفاجعه
بسقوط مئات الضحايا من الجانبين جراء
اشتباكات عنيفه استمرت لساعات طويله بين
الطرفين ومع توتر الاجواء علت لغه السلاح
على اي لغه اخرى بين الليبيين والحكومه لا
يبدو ان لديها ما تقدمه سوى المناشدات
المتكرره التي تطالب فيها التشكيلات
العسكريه بالخروج من العاصمه تنفيذا لقرار
المؤتمر الوطني العام القاضي بذلك فقدره
الدوله العسكريه لا تزال دون قدره
التشكيلات المسلحه كما اوضح رئيس الحكومه
المؤقته اكثر من مره ويخشى لهذه المشاهد
ان يكون لها ما بعدها كما يحذر كثيرون اذا
لم يتحرك اصحاب التاثير والنفوذ من قاده
الكتائب وثوار المناطق ويتوافق مع الحكومه
والمؤتمر الوطني على صيغه حل ترضي غرور
البعض وتحفظ ماء الوجه
لاخرين
ونناقش هذا الموضوع اذا في حلقتنا نناقشه
من طرابلس مع كل من عدنان القروي النائب
السابق لرئيس المجلس المحلي لمدينه طرابلس
وايضا محمد المعزب عضو المؤتمر الوطني
الليبي العام ومن مصراته عبد عبر سكايب
محمد ابراهيم المتحدث باسم لجنه اداره
الازمه نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا
ونبدا بالتطور الاخير استاذ محمد ابراهيم
في مصراته وانت المتحدث باسم لجنه اداره
الازمه في مصراته اخر تطور جاء بيان مجلس
محلي
مصراته وهذا البيان يرفض اخلاء العاصمه
الا بشروط وهو ما يبقي الازمه طبعا مفتوحه
على كل
الاحتمالات كيف نفهم ما جاء في هذا البيان
استاذ
ابراهيم نعم اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد اشرف
الانبياء والمرسلين نحن
بدايه نعزي اهالي كل الضحايا وكل ليبيا في
كل من سقط يعني قتيلا في في في في احداث
طرابلس يوم الامس وهذا الامر يحزننا ويحزن
كل اهل ليبيا في في هذه الايام العصيبه في
الواقع البيان مصرات لم يشترط اي شيء هناك
كانت يعني
مفاوضات ومباحثات منذ حوالي اكثر من اسبوع
او اكثر من ع ايام على وضع الكتائب
المسلحه اللي موجوده في طرابلس ونحن ايضا
في مصراته
الجميع متفق على
اخلاء نعم ليس طرابلس فقط و ولكن كل المدن
من المظاهر المسلحه وان الدوله تسارع في
تكوين جيش وتكوين الشرطه و تتحمل
مسؤولياتها في في هذا الامر وعندما تكلمنا
صدر بيان
من مدينه مصراته او مجلس محلي لمدينه
مصراته باخلاء طرابلس من كل الكتائب
ثم خرج بيان ايضا من منطقه او من
الموجودين الكتائب الموجوده في منطقه اروط
بانهم يخرج يعني مع اخراج او اخلاء مدينه
طرابلس كحه ولط لكن بشروط ما هي هذه
الشروط ما هي الشروط لاجد هناك شروط ما هي
الشروط اعطيني اي شط هذا هذا ما يذكره
البيان هذا
ما ان كنت ان كنت تريد ان اقرا لك بعض
الشروط اهم ما جاء في البيان نؤكد انه لا
مناص من وجود الثوار لتامين العاصمه وان
يكون ذلك في شكل منظم وتحت الشرعيه الى ان
تبرهن الحكومه عن جديتها في وضع القرار
رقم 27 الصادر عن المؤتمر الوطني العام
موضع التنفيذ باليات واضحه وم حدده نعم
نعم هذا هذا شيء طبيعي جدا اذا كان لم
توجد وايضا حتى المؤتمر ناقش هذا الامر
اذا كان لا توجد اي يعني مظاهر للجيش
ولا يعني للشرطه ولا توجد اي قوات نحن
نذكر بان هناك تكليف لدروع ليبيا والمساله
لم تكن مع درع ليبيا يعني المشكله نحن لا
نريد ان نخلط الاوراق هي المشكله كانت
يعني الناس في تاجيج نحو اي منطقه معينه
وهي منطقه غرور وهي تتواجد بعض الكتائب
وعلى فكره الكتائب لا
تنتمي فقط ولكن هذه الكتائب يوجد بها
الكثير ايضا من
كار يعني تشترون ان يتم
ايضا نزع السلاح كل التشكيلات
المسلحه الاخرى انتقل اليك سيد محمد
المعزب كيف تلقيتم هذا الموقف من
مصراته من مجلس محلي م
طبعا طبعا هو بدايه نعزي في الضحايا
ونتمنى الشفاء للجرح وهو حادث مؤسف للغايه
طبعا هز ليبيا كلها وكنا نتمنى ان لا يحدث
هذا الامر ان يقتتل ابناء الشعب الليبي
الواحد
والبيان هو طبعا انا احب ان اوضح اولا ان
بالنسبه للمؤتمر الوطني العام قد عالج هذا
الامر بشكل صريح وواضح في القرار رقم 27
اللي تحدث عن اخلاء مدينه طرابلس ثم اعقبه
بالقرار رقم 53
واللي فرق ما بين التشكيلات الغير الشرعيه
وهذه طلب من الحكومه ان تقوم بحلها فورا
ولو احتاجت الى استخدام القوه والمقصود
بالتشكيلات الغير شرعيه هي التشكيلات
الغير منضو تحت رئاسه الاركان او الداخليه
ثم جاء للتشكيلات الشرعيه اللي هي منضو
تحت الجيش او تحت الداخليه وطلب من
الحكومه ان تقدم اي تقدم بشكل واضح وصريح
خطه كامله لعمليه ادماج هذه التشكيلات
بشكل فردي اي بمعنى حل هذه التشكيلات
القرار واضح لا يقول اي فقط لكن ما ما
فائده هذا الطلب نعم استاذ معزم ما فائده
هذا الطلب او هذه الدعوه ان لم تكن هناك
قوه تنفيذ على
الارض هو طبعا المفترض في الحكومه هي
الجهاز التنفيذي المفترض فيها ان تشرع
فورا فور صدور هذا القرار بان تضع خطه
عمليه ملموسه ومحسوسه بحل هذه التشكيلات
ودمجها اما في الجيش او الشرطه اما ان
تبقى
ه مستمره
بهذا انا انا اطلب هذا السؤال يوجه
للحكومه اما بالنسبه للمؤتمر فالمؤتمر قد
ادى دوره بهذا الجانب المؤتمر الان محتاج
ان يطلب من الحكومه بالضبط ما هي
الاجراءات العمليه التي اتخذتها في هذا
الشان يعني اليس اليس من حق المؤتمر ان يس
ال
الحكومه لا نعم من حق الم
قلت من المفروض ان المؤتمر يستدعي الحكومه
ويسالها عن الاجراءات العمليه التي
اتخذتها في تنفيذ هذا القرار وهو لم ينفذ
طيب استاذ ولم ينفذ حتى الان نعم استاذ
عدنان القروي اذا يعني كما تابعنا في
البدايه مجلس بيان محلي مصراته يرفض اخلاء
العاصمه الا بشروط اذا طرابلس لن يخرج
منها هؤلاء المسلحون
موقفكم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في البدايه اعزي
انفسنا واسر الضحايا وليبيا كافه على
الحادثه التي وقعت يوم امس الجمعه اما
بالنسبه لموضوع
اخلاء منطقه غرغور سيئه الصيط في مدينه
طرابلس
للاسف واقولها الحكومه لا لا لم تتمكن من
من وضع حلول عمليه لاخلاء هذه الم طقه
بالرغم ان اهالينا في مدينه
مصراته اعلنوا في بيانات سابقه بان اي اي
قوات خارج مدينتها لا لا تنطوي تحت
الشرعيه فهي لا لا لا تمثلها وهذا طبعا
نحن الان ضروره
ضروره الذهاب الى التهدئه تهدئه بالكامل
نطالب جميع اهالينا وفي مصراته بالذات
والقوات التي دخلت لطرابلس ليله البارحه
بان تتحكم الى العقل وان تسحب القوات
لخارج لخارج لخارج المدينه نريد ان ان ان
ان نقول رساله بان الكل قوي في مناطقه نود
ان نقول رساله ان الكل ضعيف خارج مناطقه
نود ان نقول رساله ان جميع الذي يسقط
سيسقط ضحيه من ضحايا بلادنا وسنخسر الكثير
ان اننا لا لا لن يكون فائز في هذه في في
في هذا في هذا الصدام لا نريد
تطوير الموقف الى ان يكون صدام بين
مدينتين فنرجو التهد من الجميع نرجو التهد
من وسائل الاعلام نرجو التهدئه من المجالس
المحليه كذلك والحكماء بصفه عامه ان ان
الوضع بهذا الشكل لن يخدم احد لن يخدم
ليبيا ولن يخدم جاراتها ولن يخدم مدنها
ولا اهلها سيد محمد ابراهيم يعني هل
تقبل نعم محمد ابراهيم هل تقبل مصراته مثل
هذه الدعوه الاحتكام الى العقل وتسليم
السلاح والدوله في النهايه ستبقى هي الجهه
الوحيده المخوله استخدام
السلاح نعم نحن مع هذا بقوه نحن مع تكوين
الجيش مع ان تكون في ليبيا دوله قويه اولا
اريد ان انوه بان ان لا يوجد صراع بين
مدينتين وكان يعني صراع بين طرابلس طرابلس
هذه عاصمتنا هذه عاصمه كل الليبيين نحن
نعتز بطرابلس ونحن نعتبر طرابلس هذه جزء
لا يتج ه هل يحق لكل منطقه ان تحمل السلاح
وتذهب الى طرابلس لا لا لا ل لا يوجد احد
يحمل السلاح ويذهب الى طرابلس هناك يعني
نحن نعرف بان توجد في طرابلس كثير من قوات
ال الثوار ومن كتائب من جميع المناطق ليست
من مصراته فقط فلا نريد ان نوجه هذا الامر
في هذا الاتجاه
انما الامر نحن اذا كان يتكلم على قوات
موجو موجوده في طرابلس نحن نعلم بمجرد
وجود اي يعني قوات نكنكن نعم طالما ان
انكم موافقون استاذ ابراهيم يعني عليكم ان
تقدموا تنازلات في هذا
الاتجاه اي التنازلات موجوده نحن عرضنا
على ال يعني حتى في منطقه غرول اللي تتكلم
عليه كان في هناك اتفاق تام لتسليمها الى
الى الدروع التابعه الى رئاسه الاركان وهي
يعني جهه شرعيه ولهم ارقام عسكريه ويدفعون
الجيش الليبي وان كان تعتبر قوه احتياطيه
والدروع يعني من من كل الاماكن
لماذا لم
يطبق الحال الاتفاق هو هو هو هو الوقت
يعني نحن الان الاتفاق حصل الاسبوع الماضي
يعني منذ من اقل من خمسه ايام والبيان صدر
وموجود على القنوات الفضائيه لم يعطى
الفرصه الكامله هناك يعني اناس متمركزون
لهم يعني الان اكثر من سنتين فكيف يعني
تتوقع ان يتم
اي يعني انهاء هذه الاجراءات في يوم او
اثنين ولكن هناك كان استباق من يعني بعض
الاناس الذين يريدون ان يعفون الفوضى
ويريدون
ان ل انا لا اتكلم عن المتظاهرين السلمين
نحن كنا معهم وكنا على اتصال معهم وكنا
نحذر تماما من ان تحدث اي اختراقات في في
هذه المظاهرات
ولكن للاسف
وقع المحضور بدا اطلاق النار من بعض
العمارات من من خات حصلت في المظاهره وحصل
ما حصل نحن الان لا نريد ان ننقي اللائم
على هذا او ذاك ولكننا نحن مع التهزئ مع
الان قو
الجش دعيني اكمل الفكره دعيني اكمل الفكره
ثم نستطيع ان نستمر نحن
هذه دنا ان تستلم الدروع مهامها تستلم كل
المقا العسكريه سواء في غرغور او في اي
اماكن اخرى يعني في في طرابلس نحن لا ن
الموضوع
لي فصل طبعا هذه الروايه التي تقدمونها
للاحداث التي حدثت في
طرابلس بعد فاصل قصير سوف
نناقش بعد الاثار المترتبه على استمرار
المظاهر المسلحه خارج سلطه الدوله الليبيه
مشاهدينا لا تذهبوا
بعيدا مشاهدينا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش التطورات الامنيه في
ليبيا بعد سقوط عشرات القتلى ومئات الجرحى
في اشتباكات طرابلس سيد محمد العزب يعني
الان في ظل هذا المشهد السياسي المحتقن
جدا نتساءل ما الحلول الممكنه هل ستبقى
الحكومه مستمره دائما في القاء اللوم على
اطراف اخرى
وتبرر موقفها الحالي العاجز في الواقع عن
انهاء المض المظاهر المسلحه في طرابل في
ليبيا بشكل
عام لا هو هو الحقيقه الاوراق مختلطه يعني
مختلطه مع بعض يعني لا يجب ان نضع اللوم
على جهه دون جهه لان المشكله مشكله وجود
السلاح ووجود المسلحين يجب ان لا ننسى ان
هناك اكثر من 18000 هارب من السجون وهؤلاء
عليهم احكام كبيره من الاعدام الى المؤبد
وهؤلاء الان جزء كبير منهم يحمل السلاح
ويدعوا ان انهم من الثوار هناك اعداد
كبيره جدا من اشباه الثوار وهم ليسوا
بثوار يحملون السلاح واصبح بالنسبه لهم
يعني مصدر رزق هذا السلاح يستطيع ان
يتحصلوا به الاموال سواء عن طريق النهب
اوض يخذ راتب من
الدوله نعم وهناك الكثير ممن ياخذ راتب من
الدوله يعني الرقم اللي موجود عندنا
المسجل على الاقل على الاقل اكثر من
100000 هل يعقل ان في ليبيا فيها 100000
مقاتل طبعا رقم خيالي ولكن رغم ذلك
الحكومه والمؤتمر يعني تغاضى عن هذا الامر
ووضع خطط من ضمن هذه الخطط هي ارسال اعداد
كبيره جدا يعني خلال العام القادم سيتم
ارسال على الاقل 1000 مقاتل في دورات
تدريبيه في امريكا وبريطانيا وفتحت دورات
هنا وتم ادماج هنا وياخذون في مرتبات
ومكافات اذا كان هؤلاء الاخوه هؤلاء
المواطنين لا يدركون ان ليبيا لن تبنى اذا
استمرت هذه الانتهاكات وهذه المسائل اللي
هي زعزعه الامن لن تبنى ليبيا ولن يكون
هناك دستور وسوف يكون اثارها سلبيه على
ليبيا لمدى لمدى طويل المستقبل اذا لم
يدركوا ذلك وان هذا وان هذا الامر سيلحق
هم في البدايه ليس فقط المواطنين الاخرين
لابد ان يكون هناك وعي على ان ليبيا في
مفترق طرق اما ان نبني هذه الدوله ونبني
دوله المؤسسات ويستطيع كل الليبيين ان
ينعم بخيراتها و وبالتالي يجب ان ينضوي
هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين عندهم رغبه ان
يستمروا في حمل السلاح من خلال وزاره
الداخليه ووزاره الدفاع كافراد وليسوا
كتشكيل ولهم مرتباتهم ومكافات وتقديرهم
والا اذا استمرت هكذا تشكيلات مسلحه وكل
واحد عامل كتيبه وداير عليها علامه معينه
ورقم معين ويبتز الدوله وياخذ في اموال
ومكافات ويستطيع ان يصل الى ما يريد ان
يصل السلاح لن تبنى دوله بهذه الح طيب
استاذ عبان القروي ليبيا وستحدث استاذ
عدنان يعني نريد ان ان نتحدث في هذا الجزء
الثاني عن الحلول الممكنه تتوقعون مثلا
تفهما من
المسلحين لمطالب يعني نزع السلاح او تسليم
السلاح ام انه سيكون بالعكس تصعيد من جانب
المسلحين يعني هل هناك حلول ممكنه لفرض
سيطره الدوله على حمل السلاح في
ليبيا بكل تاكيد هناك حلول ممكنه لو توفرت
الاراده السياسيه بكل تاكيد نحن الان امام
حكومه عاجزه او لم لم تقدم شيء في هذا
الملف للاسف لحد الان لم نرى اشياء ملموسه
في في هذا الموضوع ولكن علينا ان نعمل
معها النقطه الثانيه ال التي نتكلم عليها
القضاء والعدل في الدوله الليبيه للاسف
التفعيل بالكامل لم يتم تفعيل طبعا
للاسباب الامنيه لان القضاء لاي لا لا
يستطيع ان يعمل في هذه الاجواء فان لم
تتوفر ظروف التي المفترض ان نعمل عليها
لتوفيرها لاجل القضاء ولاجل الامن لاجل
بسط الامن لا نقدر ان نتقدم خطوه هناك
طبعا الفرص موجوده ولكن لابد من وجود
اراده سياسيه اما ال لابد ان نعلم ايضا
اننا نحن الان في بدايه تاسيس الدوله اما
التنافس بين الكيانات او غيره ل ل خارج
قبه البرلمان الى الى الى الشوارع داخل
المدن فهذا لا يجوز لابد ان ان يعي
السياسي في ليبيا والغير سياسي في
ليبيا والمواطن بصفه عامه اننا الان في
فتره تاسيس لابد ان نقف معا صفا واحدا من
لاجل بناء الدوله
اما الذي يريد ان يجلب مزايا الى منطقته
او مزايا الى الى مدنه او مزايا شخصيه
لنفسه او غيره او يريد ان ان يغتنم فرصه
قبل ان تبنى الدوله فنقول ان ان انكل كلنا
نفكر نفس التفكير لابد ان تبنى الدوله في
الاول لابد ان ان ناخذ سنه او سنتين او
ثلاثه او اربعه او خمس سنوات لبناء
المؤسسات ودعم الدوله بصفه عامه بسط الامن
تفعيل القضاء وغيره من من من ظروف واهمها
الي نتكلم عليها العداله الانتقاليه وندخل
بعدها الى المصالحه الوطنيه هذه كلها ظروف
ضروري ان نحن محمد ابراهيم يعني نظريا كل
كل هذا الكلام كل هذا الكلام الذي استمعنا
اليه كلام ج جميل وكلكم متفقون على ان
الدوله يجب ان تفرض سيطرتها على الارض
وعلى حمل السلاح وان تقضي على مظاهر
التسلح لكن الواقع مغاير تماما الواقع
مؤلم ما المطلوب ولنبدا من مصرات ما الذي
يمكن ان تفعلوه انتم
ا نعم الواقع لا شك بانه مؤلم اعتقد
المسؤوليه تقع على اصحاب القراب الاصحاب
الذين لديهم سلطه الان وخاصه
والحكومه الان يبدون في تكوين الجيش انا
يعني لا نقول تفعيل الجيش لانه لا يوجد
جيش في
ليبيا بالنسبه ل نظام الم لجيش في ليبيا
فقع يجب على الحكومه والمؤتمر الوطني وضع
اليات لت جيش ل عقيده سليمه يعني عقيده
وطنيه لليبيا وعند ذلك الوقت انا متاكد
بان كل الثوار الحقيقيين سي سيسلمون
اسلحتهم او
سينضمون لهذا الجيش المجهود الموجود للاسف
لان الى الان يعني لا توجد اي لم نعرف
ماذا تريد الحكومه ماذا يريد المعتبر من
هؤلاء الثوار يعني ان يرموا باسلحتهم الى
البحر او ماذا يفعلون الان لا توجد اي
مؤسسات في الدوله يعني كجيش او ما يسمى
بجيش او كذا حتى يسمن اليهم اللاح او
ينضموا
اليهي التي التي
امت
هل الحكومه ال ربما تشجع على التظاهر هذا
التظاهر السلمي ضد الميليشيات او الجماعات
المسلحه كحل بديل لعجزها عن السيطره على
الوضع لا هو هو الحكومه لا لا لا يعني هذا
ليس هروب من المسؤوليه ولكن مشكل مشكل
عاملي يعني لما تجي تطلب من اي تشكيل
وتطلب منه ان يحل نفسه ويدخل يقول وماذا
التشكيل الاخر وهكذا انا ادعو الثوار
الحقيقيين ان ياخذوا قياده هذا الامر ان
ان يعقدوا مؤتمرا عاما لهم ويحددوا يوم
محدد ويتم حل هذه التشكيلات في وقت واحد
ويتم دمجها اما في الداخليه او في الدفاع
حسب رغبات كل شخص وينتهي هذا الامر
وبالتالي نقطع الطريق على الاخرين لان
هناك كثير جدا من هذه التشكيلات تشكيلات
غير شرعيه ل انتم في المؤتمر الوطني انت
عض في المؤتمر يعني المؤتمر الوطني ماذا
يفعل لدفع الامور بهذا
الاتجاه بالنسبه للمؤتمر الوطني دوره هو
دور رقابي وتشريعي بالنسبه للتشريعات
اللازمه اصدر ثلاث قرارات متواليه ومهمه
وحساسه وخطيره لو تم تنفيذ واحد منها كان
يكفي والدور الان على الحكومه ولكن
الحكومه تقول انها عندما تخاطب اي من
التشكيلات يقول انا مستعد نحل لكن الاخر
لازم يحل وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان الثوار
الحقيقيون ليس الثوار مزيفون اذا كانوا
يريدوا ان ينقذوا ليبيا من هذا المصير
المظلم الذي نراه الان امامنا عليهم ان
يتحركوا ويتفقوا على موعد محدد ومعين ويتم
حل هذه التشكيلات ودمجها في الداخليه
والدفاع وننتهي من هذا الامر اما ان كل
واحد يتحجج بان الاخر هو عليه ان يتقدم
بهذه الخطوه اولا ثم انا ساتبع هكذا
سنستمر بهذه الحاله ولن نصل الى نتيجه نعم
عدنان القروي اي مستقبل سياسي باخ صار اي
مستقبل سياسي ينتظر ليبيا في ظل هذا
الاحتقان وهذا
الوضع بكل تاكيد حتكون هناك صعوبات في اي
مستقبل سياسي او حتى لصياغه دستور في ظل
هذه الاجواء فلا بد من من فعل شيء
ل لتحسين الاجواء داخل داخل الدوله بكل
تاكيد اننا في مازق لابد على الحكومه ان
تبدو الجهد في تنفيذ قراراتها لابد على
المؤتمر الوطني ال ان ان يخرج علينا
بحلول
بحلول بحلول واقعيه وعمليه نحن ك كمواطنين
او من او مؤسسات المجتمع المدني ممكن ان
ندعم بكثير من الافكار نطالب نطالب مثلا
تقنين وتنظيم السلاح وللاسف هذه خطوه لم
تتخذ لحد الان لا قد تكون خطوه سحب السلاح
خطوه مازال مازال ما زالت مبكرا ولكن ممكن
ان ان نبدا بتقنين وتنظيم السلاح اشكرك
عدنان القروي النائب السابق لرئيس المجلس
المحلي لمدينه طرابلس ونشكر ايضا الاستاذ
محمد المعزب عضو المؤتمر الوطني الليبي
العام وايضا نشكر ضيفنا من مصرات محمد
ابراهيم المتحدث باسم لجنه اداره الازمه
في مصراته وبهذا تنتهي مشاهدينا هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده لما وراء خبر
جديد لكم منا اطيب المنى
[موسيقى]
ا